comment soulager le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés au sein des entreprises on en
parle avec vous bertrand dumazy bonjour
bonjour david chaque année à l'état des
pdg d'edenred alors avant de parler de
vos solutions elles sont nombreuses pour
pour favoriser pour soutien pouvoir
d'achat déjà est ce qu'on est bien loti
quand on est un salarié edenred sur fond
quand une fois d'inflation et 5%
d'inflation à ce qu'on perd du pouvoir
d'achat quand on est salarié d'edenred
dont on gagne du pouvoir d'achat et
heureusement puisqu'on ne les champions
du monde de l'argent fléchés et donc de
la redistribution davantage aux salariés
et donc elles vont en parler bon on
parle des nôtres mais on parle de 2
millions de salariés dans le monde
puisqu'on à 50 millions d'utilisateurs
de nos solutions et on est présent dans
46 pays sur vos salariés sur les
salariés devraient bien sûr mais je jeu
puisqu'on fait ça partout dans le monde
d'abord on va s'occuper de nos salariés
donc est ce qu'on est bien loti d'abord
en france on a été augmenté en moyenne
de 3 2% alors que pour les salariés de
l'ensemble du corps français on est
plutôt aux alentours de 2% à l'inflation
qui sera pris au tour 2 5% alors on a
encore du temps pour pour pour faire
d'autres choses mais on n'a pas fait que
ça deuxièmement évidemment comme on est
leader mondial du ticket restaurant dans
le monde le ticket restaurant chez
edenred est à son maximum et il est
cofinancé par l'employeur c'est à dire
moi à hauteur de 60 % ce qui est
quasiment unique en france puisqu'on est
plutôt à 50/50 troisième mandat pousser
à fond le ticket cadeau kadéos leader
également mondiale produit edenred 250
euros pour chaque collaborateur et puis
comme nos affaires tourne bien il y a de
la participation et d'intéressement qui
peuvent représenter jusqu'à un mois de
salaire sur l'année 2021 bon quand on
voit l'action edenred j'ai regardé sur
sur cinq ans on a plus que doublé et
comme vos salariés peuvent participer à
cette création de valeur cette création
cet enrichissement de votre entreprise
est ce que vous seriez prêt pourquoi pas
allez soyons fous à distribuer des
actions gratuites au pur pour les
collaborateurs pour qu'ils soient
actionnaires alors on le fait déjà c'est
à dire que j'ai inventé l'eau chaude
mais donc on a des programmes d'actions
gratuites chaque année et qui concerne
en gros quatre cents personnes dans
l'entreprise sur dix mille salariés
après chaque collaborateur vite fait
mais c'est déjà un bon début puisque 400
sur 10000 à 7 un ratio qui est assez
généreux et c'est bien normal et
deuxièmement c'est des programmes qui
ont lieu chaque année donc vous avez des
entreprises où c'est une fois tous les
trois ans et nous il ya des allocations
qui tombe chaque année ce qui fait du
pouvoir d'achat en plus ce qui fait du
pouvoir d'achat en plus bon edenred il
faut le rappeler ce sont des solutions
de paiement pour les salariés il faut
expliquer en quoi c'est un système
gagnant gagnant pour le salarié
l'employeur vous l'expliqué très bien
c'est à dire que sur le ticket resto une
part est financé par le salarié une part
par l'employeur mais il n'y a pas de
cotisations pour le salarié ait ni par
l'employeur il se battait pas d'impôts
non plus désocialisés défiscaliser je me
disais mais c'est gagnant gagnant mais
pour l'état s'est permis puisque des
cotisations en moins et de l'impôt en
moins bien dire qu'elle aille à la tva
qui rentre alors ce que je vais vous
dire c'est que tous les calculs qui ont
été fait soit par les économistes
keynésiens soit par les économistes
libéraux on arrivait à quelque chose qui
est unique c'est à dire que les deux
convergent sur le même constat en disant
quand l'euro quand l'état met un euro en
investissement de défiscalisation sur du
ticket restaurant il en récupère un euro
60 une autre manière de le dire ce
système est aussi gagnant pour l'état
qui en gros gagne à 900 millions d'euros
par an ça lui coûte un milliard quatre
et il en tire 2 milliards 3 donc c'est
gagnant gagnant gagnant c'est gagnant
gagnant gagnant gagnant puisque les
restaurateurs ont dû volumes
supplémentaires en france et environ 4
milliards 2,7 milliards de volume qui va
en fait directement chez les
restaurateurs le salarié c'est du
pouvoir d'achat l'employeur c'est de la
rétention est une adaptation nouveau
mode en fait de consommation pas
uniquement la cantine mais avec le
télétravail la cantine et du ticket
restaurant et ses gagnants également
pour l'état en fait c'est je trouve que
c'est vraiment le symbole
du dialogue social à la française qui
fonctionne c'est à dire que vous avez
ces quatre parties prenantes qui se
mettent d'accord sur des règles un peu
contraignantes pour chacun mais en
acceptant ces règles et en jouant jeu
chacun gagne et on est capable de
l'exporter dans 45 pays dans le monde il
faudra augmenter selon vous
bertrand dumazy la valeur faciale du
tiers est stocké de 11,12 euros c'est 5
millions euros environ et qu'elles qu'il
faudrait la on ne peut imaginer passer à
15 euros ça ferait vos affaires
évidemment mais ça serait bon aussi pour
le pouvoir d'achat des salariés c'est le
thème de l'émission alors oui je pense
que c'est une mesure essentielle pour le
d'achat des salariés pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord la dépense moyenne pour
déjeuner aujourd'hui et aux alentours de
15 euros or un seul ticket par jour est
de l'ordre de 11 euros et pourquoi parce
qu en fait l'augmentation annuelle a été
très faible année après année alors que
l'en réglant le surcoût des denrées
alimentaires est bien supérieur à ce que
l'évolution du ticket restaurant a rendu
c'est une première chose
la deuxième c'est que ce système
fonctionne c'est à dire que quand on a
permis aux français pendant le coc vie
de dépenser plus de manière journalière
pas sur le mois mais de manière
journalière en faisant passer plafond de
19 à 38 euros par jour les français ont
immédiatement c'est à dire le lendemain
dépenses et non plus 14 euros en moyenne
mais 21 euros donc on sait que ça
fonctionne troisièmement ses co financés
par l'employeur et l'employé rolande
burger a réalisé une étude il ya
quelques semaines en demandant aux
employés est ce que vous aimeriez mettre
plus d'argent dans ticket restaurant 70
% ont dit oui on est prêt à mettre plus
parce qu'on a besoin de plus alors que
les tickets restants il y aussi le
ticket mobilité pour pour payer son
plein d'essence et là pour le coup le
salarié s'il m'a compris ne met rien
tout est pris en charge par l'employeur
mais à quelle hauteur en france la loi
mobilité permet à un employeur de
financer jusqu'à 600 euros au travers
d'un ticket mobilité pour la mobilité de
ses collaborateurs mobilité qui a
augmenté et dont le coût a augmenté il a
augmenté d'à peu près 15 % depuis 12
mois ça veut dire que pour se déplacer
sur son lieu de travail pour des
collaborateurs français c'est de plus en
plus cher une des raisons étant le prix
de l'essence à un employé peut finir un
employeur peut financer jusqu'à 600
euros pour la mobilité de ses salariés
ça c'est du pur d'achat c'est du pouvoir
d'achat directement distribuée de
l'employeur à l'employé sans cotisation
sans cotisations sociales est ce que le
risque c'est pas que tous ces chèques
cadeaux ces tickets se substituent à des
hausses de salaires c'est une question
qui se pose
cette question est bien légitime je ne
le crois pas c'est à dire que ces sujets
sont des sujets complémentaires et
d'ailleurs moi même étant chef
d'entreprise et et en chef d'entreprise
depuis longtemps j'ai participé aux
négociations salariales annuelles donc
je peux en parler
en connaissance de cause quand vous
négociez avec vos partenaires sociaux
vous commencez toujours par
l'augmentation annuelle de salaire et
comment elles s'appliquent en fonction
des différentes catégories et en
fonction de la santé d'entreprise c'est
toujours ça et il existe toujours un
écart entre le désir bien légitime des
partenaires sociaux mais aussi de la
capacité légitimes de l'entreprise à
remplir ses désirs et il existe toujours
un écart et la manière de faire la
soudure entre les deux c'est de rajouter
ces systèmes en disant ok vous voulez 4%
mais on peut faire 3-2 mais on va faire
un effort sur les tickets restaurant
c'est à dire on va rajouter un euro et
puis on n'a pas encore deux tickets
télétravail ça s'installe allez on le
met en place et donc vous êtes capable
en panachant l'ensemble de ces mesures
de trouver un juste équilibre entre le
désir des représentants du personnel
encore une fois des désirs bien légitime
et les capacités financières de
l'entreprise et au final combien de
salariés bénéficient à la fois
esthétique et mobilité tickets resto
titres tel travail alors en france est
plus répandu en france pour les pauvres
pour les produits edenred ça représente
à peu près 3 millions de personnes 3
millions de salariés et trois millions
de salariés on se dit qu'à la marge on
se dit qu'à bourgeois 15 millions de
salariés dont il ya un peu plus de vingt
mille 20 me marier en france et là on
parle des salariés du privé parce que
vous avez toute la fonction publique qui
échappe encore à ces avantages qui sont
redonné donc on a un train la gravelle
le frein pour encore une fois les 15
millions de salariés qui n'ont pas et
donc tout ça dans toutes les entreprises
qui n'ont pas encore passé le pain alors
je pense qu'il faut le prendre produit
par produit par exemple si vous prenez
le ticket restaurant en france vous avez
une part de marché du ticket du titre
restaurant au sens générique du terme de
l'ordre de 26% vous avez encore un quart
des salariés français qui vend léventine
vous avez un quart des salariés français
qui ramène leur gamelle au travail et
vous avez un quart des salariés qui
rentre à la maison pour déjeuner je
pense que pour la gamelle et pour la
cantine cette proportion est amené à
baisser et à devenir adeptes en fait du
titre restaurant qui est globalement
moins cher à gérer pour l'entreprise et
avec un niveau de satisfaction qui est
bien supérieure pour le pur pour
l'employé donc il faut prendre en fait
comment dire programme par programme
pour le télétravail on répond se
rappelle qu'en france on a à peu près
20% des salariés français qui ont accès
au télétravail parce que vous avez des
métiers qui ne permettent pas à mettre
de ted et travailler et donc déjà on
travaille sur une base un peu plus petit
et puis c'est des programmes où il faut
faire preuve de pédagogie c'est à dire
il faut les expliquer il faut il faut
être patient il faut trouver les budgets
qui vont bien et donc ça va se
construire dans le temps on finit là
dessus juste une petite question nos
voisins belges ont des éco chèques
est-ce que c'est à regarder parce qu'on
se dit que ça pourrait permettre de
flécher les dépenses vers des produits
bio vers des produits locaux oui alors
c'est un programme qui a utilisé par 1
millions 7,2 belge je rappelle qu'en
belgique vous avez 12 millions
d'habitants et donc vous avez un million
7 de salariés belges qui ont accès à un
éco chèques c'est à dire de l'argent
fléché qui ne peut être utilisé que pour
acheter des écoproduits chez des échos
marchands c'est-à-dire des produits dits
écologique ou plus responsable derrière
ça il ya une volonté pédagogique de
l'état belge de dire il ya beaucoup de
gens qui achètent des produits non
écologique parce qu'ils n'ont jamais eu
la chance de le faire parce que la
promouvoir d'achat est un peu limité ça
coûte un petit peu plus cher donc on va
les aider à faire un premier pas et
quand ils auront fait ce premier pas
alors la chose va prendre ses 1 millions
celles de salariés en belgique
aujourd'hui si vous faites une règle de
trois pour la france ce serait 10
millions de salariés en france si on
avait le même taux de pénétration qu'en
belgique voilà ya du potentiel il ya du
potentiel de redistribution du pouvoir
d'achat les outils existent
il s'agit maintenant de les comprendre
et de les mettre en place de manière
digitale lé merci beaucoup bertrand
dumazy le pdg d'edenred merci beaucoup
merci la vie pourvu que ça dure
l'émission qui rend les co-responsables
c'est fini pour aujourd'hui magazine à
voir ou revoir sur public sénat et du
replay bien sûr
[Musique]